сьогоднішній конфлікт він повернувся
столицю україни київ
а б запитають ще залишилося та забити on
комі провести реформи це подала тій
корупцію
не є міністр zoho даних праворуч
влог клімкін закидаємо краї нам вбивається
від рпц ще й може сказати і про і за
спокійними і дам
потрапила клімкіна нас до питань про
програму conflict zone ласка питання в
україну та кобури театр російську
агресію таким я до рлс пишу приказку
про ваше венозне склеєне заходу вам
пообіцяв і безвізовий доступ до Європи
мвф за новими фінансово не і акули ви
збираєтеся і викладати свої зуби в я
зайнятий ці самі захворювання такі як
боротьба з корупцією на прогрівання
проведення реформ як ти прощений це
значить на гори в джо байден вашому
президенту кілька ти ж не в тому
тисніть
я все гляну і на тисячу вид буваєте
в Україні і я мою на вазі на тільки
діянь 100 міністра за кордоном праворуч
то ми точно зарубали більше за астану
сир і не можна по парі дні 20 та ціни
тільки створи не я зараз теми начебто б
швидку і не тільки під'їзду не сценарист
та практичний день а ліфті брухту
ціна ментальність владно став зраджу ти
сам і ланцюги трохи вона ще зрозумів ти збоку
то все інакше байден говорив про це дуже
роздутого на і з продажу вашого
президентами найсильніший за вірш чоловік
нових ви різних т.ч. годину у тілі води
вбивцею і реформи і наші крила русою
зайшовся крупі околиць готує новий the
seventh санкції проти Москви не не
зовсім на так давайте не будемо відкрито
ти себе такими фразами це можете я особи
що була присуджена за зустрічі між
нашим президентом і джо байден половин
сказав ви пряму силу цієї прямо так і не
сказавши ви принца і на ти прямий
санкції 100 суйся того що росія вдв і
ну
гібридну та проти україни ви наук
сподівалася крим та факт річковий coupe мало
donbass так що санкції за право дав і в
чим сенс цієї Росії пити з України
реформи це наше паливо поважає ще
санте задумані для team
j-pop ще на моя жадібних у знак чогось
такого санкції так нічого і треба сигми в
плані до з коліна зради ситуації на
окупованих територіях
теж як довго вивалив і помацати і
санкції вимагав та g європейський та
американський бізнес поттер ширяє
продовження санкцій по porsche та сантиму
youth засуву ти все до тих пір поки
Росія в буквальному сенсі на піт з
україни я вірю в тій усі люди та країни
цивільний рубля ви beer & c ваш вибір
aweber україни до цих ти реальних успіх
та c1000 нам sli труби ти а би випалить це
досі ти успіху
ви так посмажте а лягає і британія
ваші достовірності та морального
авторитету і всі ви дозволь цій росії
нападать і на поклади державу ви
відкриті screen q пандори
скликни devo solo a high cut в об сльозу
рази метатися ваш прем'єр-міністр пішов
до левін заявив підручники україни та кипить
вимагає зняття санкцій стануть
учасниками агресора на вашу думку
знижки з продуктивно навішують ярлик і
учасники агресор на людей цих хоче
знято санкції і дайте мені про ярлики про
емоції так і ленін зуби в самому серці
був сам ваш крім річки та новітнього
verlag та що я хочу сказати ми вич або
справжня міжнародну солідарність та c
у porsche в історії європейського союзу
cool і з проводити по слідів ну і відразу
милу політик обліку росії
understandable смуги chords and when it
виходу що потрібно була агресія проти
дні та на за лижної України щоб випросив
в цю політику і трц наш шанс з гурту
вати сяду б ти себе результатом і Петро
бо ти
міжнародної системи ще грунтується
спрямував а як щоб ви могли петром це
санкцій би ви конувала взяти на себе
забаві за ще до боротьби з корупцією та
реформ чого ви заявляєте їх європейці то
американці поки що не роботи на лижню
чином зовсім не за
це що ви просто я ж ти заяви бичкова
тут шато з то в плані реформ
то в плані того ще дрібно ну як я собі
100 поважаю
заклада нова телком стеку базу міністр
який тільки шоб вони пророкували
кілька ти ж цьому виду бачила українцю і
сказала те саме вона сказала чого мені
відкидну посилку цій боротьбі з корупцією
у таїчі реформи
вам потрібна дієта вже за раз пам'ятаю все
згода
я за зустрічався з міністра до і приз корр
тож м'язи треба сили свої і мати з чого
важа та 1000 тотальну kurumba он
україну за 2 роки реально перед шкодою та в
після свята європейську демократію то
чудово али у 2015-му роті за корупції
закруту судини ви менше людей нішу
2014 менше теж лайтеся назад я хочу
випити ним це 100 тис такого його злого
вали ксиви поглянути і на вуста не
статистичні та ні вона та ще арешт
вибиваються практичні дні як щоб
поляни таємниця систему ви критику рубці
ямале на базі антикорупційного бюро та
space прокурора скинь без корупцію щось
по залі на все ще розвивається і на
всю реформу національної поліції то ваші
слова про тягни україна рухайся назад я
ніколи серйозно на ніколи на посаді
міністра не виткова такого вночі
просто за статуї the menu
вона transparency international antutu
києві заявив а ми в хащі і ми запам'ятаємо
ще українські політики хочеш боротися
з корупцією у нас правдивий синів поки
cold хіба ти не хочеш у гість хто за і
Ваще україна рука ите us в рот йому на
премію в харчування cry for a bully мене це
дуже особливе стопи tanya віджиму віялом
його з ми боремося з корупцією та
переслідувана корупціонерів і дайте на
тільки про корупцію та деці про біржу
прозорець системи влади пропав але
реорганізацію система юстиції для повної
реорганізацію національної поліції out
до fall of naples
ось і давайте павіанам ще ваше нас його
не думаючи платі так дзвони
ранок не черні міжнародний
республіканський інститут праві досвід та
вання вона показала сімдесят один вид
соток українці поважаючий україни рухайся
у спрямованому на плівку для , рахунок
мусала б не змініть свою сумку
46 висотки пазл з косово ти імунітет
депутата та суддя
я пам'ятайте ланцюги прямо чому чого
надується
вона вимагатиме політичного консенсусу все
web це не etudes залишаться з 2 по 5 у
вас не травня політичного не дано моїм
політичного консенсусу для рук поважає
і цінує а у чура набравши щелепи цілий
пакет інституційних реформ та концепцію
того я шалений це система правосуддя
the page я з його димом друга момент
польова в тому і що буде і заманити цю
способи зграя вали кіпр охоронець того ще
адже пити на ще дали
алленом ніг хіт на мати і за гранню
національний консенсус обороти соски
вона міністра людей, чиї столи на них не
думку державної структури бірж мають
шкіру поводження
76 вид доба досвідчених ваша шукаю
прокуратура стала щуку руба в нижчу 73
вид сотки судини стала пак
корумпованим і 75 сотки в
кожну прядку чи органи став і без шкур
антонова а ви ми не заявляє ще рухайся
поет вона ж на салоні зроблю вам ще ви
ляльку і ти назад танець вона так і
пізніше ніж у салаті цифри говорять самі
за себе ось вдається прориву не враховувати
то хто про троянду мене того що якщо труби
знає про вас а швидко в ми не так вже
надзвичайно високий rival враховувати і
шкіра заряду всіх павільйон 2 повідати йому
ревниво чикова сама з кардинально
видозмінюється виток ще буду раниш і
алла шукає цього шукають і руку перед тацю
однозначно так і цілі дно на конкретних
прикладів три чверті вашого населення
не поважають вже розруха висновок і на
справедливий суд
спаміш тих хто сорти всього суддю
тридцять один вид суду кореспонденті
заявив ще офіційний представник
суду вимагав і видних хабар обдурити
кінці висипеш
це я на видуву менше стрибнути за по
передні влади знаєте я добрий по
кидаються тому не
українським судам довіряв і лише 4 види
добу населення представляє і тільки 4
сотки українців на витек що вони c
здавалося диким з меншим і мати іншим
захворюванням то нині абсолютно інста
ситуація голим і при мені йому результати
випитували про rewind прибери палець та це
diy за раз тараниш це була брехня знову
а сьогодні то 50 з плюсів і
Різниці вона міністр оптимізму і туди я і
тисяч від села квартир формату raw
офіційних осип імені склади свої
повно важливо на прокладку лише не міністр
економіки айварас абромавічус
вінди show with ставку у лютому
заявив про менеджери бізнес-імперії
президента продовжити силу в руку тільки
посилати свої позиції пригладити винного
раціону постріл від треба жанрі
турагентствах Аліна рази вся на опер
чим ваше чищення у вас був міністр охорони
Олександр здоров'я котиш вели нам
заводила система сказав він до цементу
волосся у підошву стане 20 5 років
тепер ви надумаєте ви штук ну ти нас я
хочу журі для тіла
вас ланцюга тбо юрія ми не повинні пити
бар'єр це ще було зароблено у
державному секторі економіки у плані
реальних реформ
здаєте виживе і вузол 7 різних кольорах і
steam леді думка здаєте циви кольору та
таки сильніший джерело бою скажу вам дві
мови я кольору і ти формату не кипиш за
своїх passat цілком не розчарування
vici і через нинішню ситуацію а я знаю
реформаторів за крима та заступники у
міністра у нашому міністерстві економіки
такі послід протирають на точилку в
цю зраду та підхід до закривання
державним і під спадкоємство ми всі що
соусі та системи охорони здоров'я я як ви
знаєте тепер перу я українка марі
канського пригоди
одна з дружиною яких я страшний про обожнюю
вона висловлює глибина її реформи
дуже випадуть Віталія Каскад
window один вибух am відрив примарних
розібралися із внутрішньої проблеми
генпрокуратури та на марсі розібратися
чому прокурори йому рубати
очевидніший випад до корупції на уявну
але я на око надумала їсти прокурори за
плющова думати дуже ще мета інтересах
карен вид-во вин заявив про беззаконня вона
верховенства права по але я в Україні
але сьогодні лікарі до уваги всі ви до
реформ і Петро мав на увазі промови
США та Євросоюз євро hовий честі проти
команди викравши із шоу з нашим новим
прокурором цілісної найкраще
підтвердження того ще ми рухнемо з
автори і цілісно ти ще хочу сказати
інше . впарять то нікого на і простягла
дме по дальності за швидко над сотні
демонстрації у 2013 2014 ми руках жадібна
анти корупції на право пов'язана з
татом одним режимом януковича
дивишся ладу суду жадібно у років заявляю
ще до 40 мільярдів доларів
знак лева ви жадібні коло фіни
виправлені змогли довести до суду та
викаже і манікюр вухо це себе у парі
послухай це я геть і факторний п'ять років
жити в четвер в той же час на рубці на
зведеш лад суду
чи 1100 метушні майдану з правді душі йому
ціни харчування для всіх нас лікую робіт
відриваємо націй момент про ітан тисячі і
тисячі людей і я абсолютно vpn вона йому
тому саме особиста точка зору
чим і з малюємо вона тільки ти ще
залишаються на майдані
oleg perets а будинок по стану thicc
побачили і за всю трагедію
не
люди зовсім туманів визнання ви
прикладом президент київської школи
економіки ти мафії милованів кажи нічого
не змінилося а пригладити тихіше чи ти
кишках і але візуально і зачарування
бетонування не праві абсолютно моя
думка потрібно просто їх все взятий ревінь
враховувати багатьох багатих українців
win просто вали чесний та світі і вам
враховував і чесний і я рублю значно
більше аби лома жив його бавитися
не людей у ​​плані цифри форум так ви були
чесні і готові з примати їх не про
позиції абу на віа дель пополо
а на кого заходити мопра корупції чому
ви просто не знаєте себе не скаже і воно
проникло всюди на виході наніс на
закохуватися руки при владі парасольки бату
олігархи диких доводиться трепет і б вам
споживає не допомогу про боротьбу проти
сепаратистів і їх петр i moi руси чому
сепаратистами кипить пряму росію
ви wan і контролює більше архімаг
фанати в полон на подібному результаті країни
і на сході на донбасі думка церковна
і дуже ми вже можемо про самість
навпаки батько росію справа гаспара що
навіть милого нам допомагає акули ріжучу
але ж знаючи куди ви політично
корениться в чоловіки плати ти як
гарантія б спати і бізнес інтереси
таких опонентів
так-то ви вигляд купаєтесь образливих мені
пояснити ми не я киу тему з
petcube і те де кі їх олігархи
боротьби з росією для монет озвучити і
трохи бажилін of fame & soul hawk
головною віссю
україна довідки було тотального
корумповану україну і ми ви не
ніби чесним і сюди потяг у нас є три
основні рівні корупції
корупції на ревниви соку по саду
корупції рада дар службу в собі по
завжди на корупцію і досі у нас
нерухомість run кованих клин and it feels
the expressions треба бути і деки години б
викуреної корупції і будь бове
дверцятами цінним вузли озеро б ти за 1 2
місяця оліг що павлину ти чого ми вже
досягли
то ви не може з 3
ж у це ще нині kurupt ціна такому
стародавні наприклад двору до цього всі сто
суеца системних реформ то я київ замовленням
ми говоримо про малюка про боротьбу з
корупцією
з іншого національна поліція та
повністю зоряний електронний реєстр
шкіра можна зайти на сайт і на давати та
жадібних а борь ю лів середовища не володіємо
травня на вазі в цей ну візуальну рис
витрачаєте бо люди б помру денну руку
call it 2 u редакції міністр уточни
праворуч сина вакуум і губернатор одеської
області Михайло Саакашвілі по чоловік
кричать і обзивати води на 1 у взводі
сволота
дівчина в наш журнал і 1 в 1 водою
виключено так-то ви владні я там т 2
клас на тему до його сплющило
алоіс глаша все спокійні може його
стиснутий ns 1 кому ви tranque у нашому
ready
теж не хвалитеся а як 4 що ви
намагаєтеся аспект октан своїх ікол cfs
емоції cfc пристрасті до нас з c
скандал як домобуд людям душі охриде
розколу володарю лазні
її зовсім не давиться у вкрай вигляд
буваєте притворі ним ми бор-омісес
російське в росію за цикл обставлено ви
за ви не робот йому цінними
ви по ви небудь і упередженими як нами
небо у нас буде така команда як у нас
е потрібно наводити один від дому називав
його ден а але зло не клоун у нього що
воли словесну перепалку через steel
внутрішня політика c
а президент був би з силою зуб імітація
ваш бачіли вижив і там всередині чи капелюх
таким вже буде й кумедний ананасом пар
цього нам про [ __ ] іди і волю добра
давайте ще поговоримо про реформи
україни його якусь сімкін ще давно
заявив і українському уведу простою за
спокій не
і дайте про ситуацію через піддони
журналістам в Україні засіки сайт під
назвою
творець пов'язані з членами вашого уряду
на рахунки навик love online
особливості так немає тисяч за хен джуна
листя та члену увагу груп
икеа 3 мл і відкритістю сепаратисти на
сході країни
он і викл і в інтернет особливості так
не це назвав особи та журналісти до
лаборантами терористів у супер та вашим
зуби в'язанням і вашим законам йти і
монада сі на сайті чому ви не отрута на клуні
і ти стоїш підборі не доносили його не
зовсім не ту ту Києву ніхто нікого на
пітбуля
як що говорить і про свободу слова
Україна до його випалений такий приклад
свободи ви проливали протест ван ейк
висимо кільця було очевидно нота протесту
моя позиція абсолютно чітко моя позиція
на стіл добу в чітко як ми можна
прилюдної тієї події та не людей і
кіназ правді та друзям в україни all is
трояндами то й ви люду і тут в Україні
ніхто і дадуть і roo'ra стива донецьк і
луганськ
про 3 травня реєстрацію то на шляху ми кубачі
тут і ті люди наш ніяк не бореться за
російську агресію самим fighter і
бджоли вона справа значно серйозніша
міністерство захід сонця він виправив і до
британії вислала вам свій я глибоко за
світ спокій не ще до fila сайту та заявила
че
вин підриває дух і букву української
законодавства
і кочітку відшкодуючого слабкості
може розкрити і терпіти результати
самої любин і клінт вулиці пруша я
міжнародний забув я за не україна теж
я заплітаю вас розум з британським виглядом
чому ви нічого не роботи з людьми
ці порушиш закон овочі клей ми відро
бувало дуже читку заявлений ми заявив ще
ціни у порожній подорожі нічому так
сталося я ще на вас до
ваш міністр внутрішніх про вибухи у вина
та вина
всякі бетонні об'єкти означає на найважливіший
для мене не чекаю нко і ліберальний і
латентних сапатистів теж винний бар щит
нічого планово кращим та сайті
викаже ще за суди у c ви здається не
вінду зачитка сказали що публіка та ціни
було приємним
ls приводу іншуді реальністю таких
сайтів я будум кабула відсиланням пенсію
знає і взагалі за крутий не партнери не
купив ці на такі паяльні ванни та
вислав і протест анни протестували
плутати його а ви про ігнор вали я особливі
що за і ви продаж чуйку поклич все ще
до зійдусь і з її спосіб до силу за
одному доступі та baнecca сімка
заявляють самі закону краб до
live while the game послуг і ти моя
позиція так а я баченої та україна вигляд
даному свободі слова 5 листі засідки чую
для моєї тримав presence of house сюди
того я до взаємодії з терористами у
донецька вчи луганську це треба в море ось
і снам і
as the same того вечора буде з усім
сайтам моя позиція така ціни застосовувати
носа телком однозначно чому ви стрибку ja
цій роботі міжнародні експерти столітті
їх атіли а глянути і зрозумілі theory не
об'єкти в Україні
чому їх не пори світ публікувала чому
інспектором спад комітету оон спа
поведінку кота війни дав і виконайте
свою роботу вранці нічого руку сина так
всі свого роду спекуляції боявся б ст
управу чисел комунікації заважає
відомими відомства
ви був чоловік вони пропаний і ти свою роботу в
україні ви знаєте ні ціна так не можна
так ви не провели ні не спекулює та
ночував я нас поки ллються
ні цілий потік форми
4 числа не рухається та піт комітету оон
по парі дружина котова не переривалася свою
роботу в Україні за те, що з'явився винести
про квіти але тут зовсім не я особи що
займався ті і право тепер ми вже всі
добре я скажу вам чому так сталося
ми стегно то ванна для них та поведінці
народиш не рекомендації йохімбе це в
україні та пояс на неї, ніж іван іншим кути
і примати доступ буде яміс поливаю
тому що
чому ви можете спати доступу зусиль
ти можеш знаковою турбуватися
виписали на його в'язку протоколи кидаючи
право інспекторам оон без тата реджі
винні закладатимете рем вони
автор вийде поставлені боюся кудись
наше завоювання нав'язливі підписала ще
він обирає і силікону ось і
розбирайтеся а ось цей харчовий протокол
Будь-який вид видно і протоколу я радий же
вам легко прочитати ми з вини треба ти
доступу місіс диво і кинути pedo
здорово туртурро хабар
на лижному по воді і не за 3 мани me
to chat про куб х знайшлося про такі
об'єкти та самих даних util ipad роботи
рятували ночі ми не можу йти вас роботи
зверху боротьби з петлею петля туди
такі консультації ми все поводив
добрий та ви можете випробувати їх chevy чого
відваліть перекис перед skoda свою
роботі раз на міністра предмет
завершили наш розбір я хотів би заплутати
вас по мінську-2 інша заповідала миска 2
на та знов едель кенійського del раз на
заходь але його лучезар чарівність ти
ще український парламент без них йде
зради до конституції кидали фактично
автономію сепаратистським регіоном ще
було ключове умову і мінських думав
настей параграф 11 змінить його було в
хвали 1000 до кінця милу руку для вас
місці до молодості березня
не зовсім не анни ви не просунулась з ним
ви навику на вигляд зі своїх же мавпочок
імені моєму номеру простакуватою все поки
біля води мертва нас правдиво на березень
мінськ мінськ a simple and
мінську біля води пробачить аллах тим легше
чим від і на світ їх ви конова ти у нас з
росії та фундаментальної розбитості у
розумі не мінських кутів
Росія хоче легалізувати і російську
протекторат на донбасі робити про кований
хочеш чип україна
у хвалила децентралізацію вище після
тягу
бутово говорить і чіпі дему нас донбасу
то чапаре days донбас плит контролю gsm
чіп там за подавала справжня bespeco не
вічний і заявляє про дві сторони по
ви зазнаєте збитків і про 2 по ви не ви
con його ти догоду безладному а не моя
. але ви повинні просто обидва ми досягаємо а
фундаментального ремені bespeco на
донбасі і ми допомагаємо ася що росія
повністю виходить з вигляду та емалі на вазі
російські регулярні війська російської
з броні і там не буду російського
протекторат у автора лише описати всього
випущено цієї ви конів ти свою чесним
мінську ось устілки після чого етці ми
це на вазі такого шумова сема та принцип
цінного умова сема принципів опозиція
випали творить клуні наумову ціни
вмиватися мій принцип його позиції
донбасі повинна бути безтурботна там не
повинна бути росії для того ще
повернено і донбас назад в Україну
марина вазе український донбас в україну
інші створі ось і сном навчаюсь на кшт від
нового великого придністров'я поки що це
ж мінськ мертвий зовсім не раз я ще
відсікає а я ще каже ще мескію води
мертвим цілісно чатами ох або вони вигляд
наміченого шлях поїхали вони різновид взятих
бавитися
не розумію та че кого hill це та
розуміє трішки за раба готовий і
європейському союзу Червона рада і я
оновити сказали
зараз новий що я багата люди річки різновиду
не ви куди не ранніх мінських на рік
оборот без російської агресії та
дику ми заткнулася, а на донбасі панамі
не стану ж я до вас за долею конфлікт
він був прийнятний як у нас і добрий